Speaker 1: Let's just stick
in Florida a little bit,
because I am curious what's going on. Let's
go to David in Florida. David, welcome.
David. It's just.
Speaker 2: This is me.
Speaker 1: It is you.
Speaker 2: Cool. I love the show. I
just wanted to have a question. Something that was
on my brain a while ago. Okay. You were asked a
lot of the Republican or more Trumpian Republican
side if they can answer the simple question of,
you know, who is the president now? My thought
was, isn't that a citizenship question? If you
can answer who the president is? I'm not saying to
take away citizenship as the final result, but if
they can't answer a simple question, you know.
Speaker 3: What are we doing here?
Speaker 1: That's a good question. I don't
know. Let's see. U.S. citizenship. Questions and
answers. Um, I don't know if. Who is the current
president is on there. It very well may be.
Name your representative. Name your senator
seems to be on there. I don't see who is the
president. Let me see. Oh, no. What is the name
of the president of the United States? Yeah,
that's true. Well, listen, I don't think it'll
come as a shock to you that lots of people who
got citizenship by birth could not actually pass
the citizenship test in the United States. I mean,
we used to do like men on the street stuff where
I would ask people, who's your senator or name
any senator and tons of people wouldn't
wouldn't get those answers right. So this
goes back to the thing I was talking about with
Tamisha about, you know, probably 80% of people
are sort of like incompetent to some degree.
Speaker 2: Unfortunately, I'm going to have
to agree with you on that one. Yeah, but
I'll. I'll leave any of that, any extra
time I have to someone else from Florida.
Speaker 1: Okay. Well, I don't have anyone
else. What part of Florida are you in?
Speaker 2: I'm down in Fort Lauderdale
about an hour north of Miami.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. Yeah, that's not
that's not a bad area. I mean, listen, if I had
to live in Florida, which I'm to be totally frank,
it's not out of the possibility that I would in
the future spend significant time in Florida.
I would be in one of two places. I would either
be in the Miami area or I would be in Pensacola,
which I know sounds weird. It's like the
Panhandle, you know. But we've got some
great friends up there and you know, there's a
Jew or two in Pensacola. It's not just WASPy.
Speaker 2: I of the two, I would have to say
Pensacola would be the better choice. So you
can probably get a little bit more land. It's
probably a little bit quieter down in Miami.
I'm looking at dinner tonight and trying to make
a reservation. The reservation said you have to
spend $100 per guest. So.
Speaker 1: Oh,
is that right? What restaurant is that?
Speaker 2: This was sugar. It's just a
nice view of Miami with some seafood.
I wanted to do something a little nice,
but maybe not $200 nice. Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Hey, have you been to
Mandolin again? Bistro.
Speaker 2: I have not. I'm
going to have to look that one up, though.
Speaker 1: That's a hot place if you can get
in there. I love it there.
Speaker 2:
I appreciate it. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Okay. Thanks for the call.
Appreciate. There's David from Florida. We're
going to take the quickest of quick breaks if
you're holding. Don't go anywhere because I'm
going right back to the phones in a moment.